there's been a lot of debate over how
much influence the government should
have when it comes to parents making the
decision of whether or not to immunize
their children how do you view this
issue well thanks for the opportunity
Trish nice to be with you the way I view
it is as a surgeon general the best
thing we can do is try and educate the
public to make good decisions based on
the best science the science is clear
here that every child should be
immunized however when we consider
ideological and theological issues it
becomes complex but the individual
rights sometimes then bleed over into
society and cause a problem like we have
today with the spread of this disease
and at that point the government does
have a compelling interest in keeping
society healthy how does how do the
rules now stand I mean if you're going
to send your child to public school or
private school for that matter I
remember having to submit my children's
eliminate immunization forms before they
enrolled isn't there some kind of
barrier there where basically you can't
go to school without having gotten the
shots yes and no most school districts
still have those rules there is no
federal mandate for that so it's done
state-by-state what often happens though
is there are exemptions exemptions
because of personal beliefs because of
religion because of ideology and in some
states it's very easy to get a waiver
others make sure that you go to a doctor
if it's a medical reason so it's very
uneven throughout the United States and
that creates problems because youngsters
who don't get immunized become vectors
of disease and they spread disease
besides adding to the cost of health
care in our nation seems very important
changement get immunized is that nasals
had been completely wiped out in this
country yes until recent has been it's
true yeah it has been and unfortunately
because of a lot of spurious information
people that are being driven by emotion
and ideology they're choosing not to
have their children immunized and that
really causes a problem for society you
know but up until recently I mean the
science was very much in question and so
it was logical that a lot of people
debated whether or not this was in fact
the healthiest thing for their children
you know some
that those reports that have since been
reversed dr. Carmona however is there
something to be said for making sure
that these immunizations are done in
stages so that a child is not getting
all of it in one go it's a very good
point and that's why various
organizations who have responsibilities
from the FDA to pediatricians and others
who look at the dosing will often look
and see what the temporal relationships
are between those adjust to make sure
that the child's immunity is built up
gradually and not overwhelmed so it's a
very good point and you should follow
the directions of your pediatrician the
CDC is warning that this outbreak is in
fact going to spread do you agree do you
foresee this becoming a real epidemic a
serious problem in this country well
it's a serious problem right now as you
said you know over the past half-century
we've eradicated measles except for a
sporadic out great and it's increasing
now because we know that some children
aren't being immunized if we don't get
this under control that can spread and
the CDC is correct this can cause a
major health problem as well as an
increased disease burden at a time when
cost of care is very important to us now